una agenda carga de tensiones
geopolíticas el segundo día del foro
económico mundial en davos estuvo
marcado por dos temas que sobresalieron
la guerra en Ucrania y el papel de china
en la economía mundial
la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula Under Legend aprovechó su
discurso para reiterar el respaldo del
bloqueo Ucrania entregando Este martes
tres mil millones de euros la primera
parte de una nueva ayuda económica
Este es el primer tramo de nuestro
paquete de ayuda de 18.000 millones para
2023 la asistencia macrofinanciera más
grande de la historia a un tercer país
por su parte la primera dama ucraniana o
Lena zelensca repartió una serie de
cartas con el plan de paz del presidente
zelenski a los representantes de la
Unión Europea y China el país asiático
también apareció en la locución de
Wonder Legend quien criticó los
obstáculos chinos hacia la transición
energética
china ha estado alentando abiertamente a
las empresas que consumen mucha energía
Europa y en otros lugares a trasladar
toda o parte de su producción lo hacen
con la promesa de energía barata bajos
costos laborales y un entorno
regulatorio más indulgente
china hizo un balance de la eliminación
de sus restricciones de Kobe 19 se
mostró dispuesta a abrir sus puertas al
mundo y optimistas sobre su recuperación
económica después de que se conociera
que el país solo creció un 3% en 2022
en general la transición ha sido estable
y sin problemas el tiempo para alcanzar
la cima y volver a la normalidad ha sido
relativamente rápido
el Foro de Davo se prolongará hasta el
20 de enero se espera que temas como el
cambio climático y las secuelas de la
pandemia en la economía continúan siendo
unas de sus grandes protagonistas